Let's go back to our grocery store dataset to make this a little more concrete.
I decided that I wanted to bring back the botanical name columns we deleted before.
I'm going to show you first how to do this in the Query settings applied steps,
and then the Advanced Editor.
Then for good measure, I'm going to intentionally break it,
and show you how you can noodle through how to fix it.
First, another microscale.
Sometimes I close out of Query Settings,
because I want to see more of the columns to the right,
and it can be really annoying if you're newer to this,
and you can't find the Query Settings to get it back.
Let me just show you briefly,
it's here under View,
and this gear right here is your homing begin to bring it back.
Here on the last step,
we have removed some other columns,
and we can see with this widget to the right,
that we can make an adjustment.
Let's go ahead and open that up.
Here, we've removed other columns is giving you a shortlist of the columns to keep.
We're just going to click Botanical name,
and there it is, right back.
But, let's make it a little bit more difficult on ourselves, and click.
A second option you could take,
is up here we have just one line of the M code right here,
so we had Removed Other Columns,
and here it's referencing that prior step here,
see for Change Type.
Change Type, and it saying Table select to keep.
We have the PLU, Category,
Commodity, Variety, and Size.
I'm just going to manually type in in all caps, BOTANICAL NAME.
I'm just going to hit this little guy right here for the checkmark, and there it is.
Let's try one more.
Home is where the Advanced Editor lives right here.
Click on the Advanced Editor,
and this gives us all of our individual steps one-by-one.
Again, remember these are going to have the same names over here,
as they do here,
with the exception of navigation,
which is always something funky like Produce Sheet.
All I'm going to do here is just add to the last step,
just like I did before, BOTANICAL NAME.
Done. It pops up here automatically,
it's already applied here,
so if we clicked on this,
you can see it already applied to that user interface,
and the applied steps,
or the Query Settings pane,
and it's back for us.
What if we decided we wanted to constrain the produce to just list apples.
We wanted to do so earlier on in
our applied steps to cut down on the number of rows earlier.
Well, we can do that at the logical end of the applied steps so far,
and we can move it up to be beneath promoted headers.
But any step above this would generate an error,
because the column name commodity wouldn't exist before the columns were promoted.
Let me show you what I mean.
I'm going to start by filtering for apples.
That will add a step,
here's my Filtered Row step.
I can move that to under Promoted Headers,
and it causes no problems whatsoever.
But if I move it above,
we get this error right here for the field saying that commodity wasn't found.
This Filter Row step has a reference that Power Query can't use.
What we can do instead,
is we can either move it below Promoted Headers,
that'll work fine, or I can leave it there if I really want it there.
I can recognize that column 3 has the first row of commodity as its value,
and I can see that column 3 has commodity as the first value listed,
and I can rename this column 3.
That'll work too. Now, I have a much shorter list.
If we go back to the Advanced Editor,
we can see that the step that we did to constrain the data set just to apples,
is here in the same order that we placed in the Query settings.
But, let's say that I changed my mind.
I don't want to filter this data set to just apples before,
and I'm in a rush,
so I'm just going to delete it, and try to move on.
What do you think will happen?
Well, you're going to end up with an error,
and it's going to ask you,
did you miss a module reference?
This what we've done, is we've just ripped apart a couple of pieces in our knitting,
and there's no corresponding stitch to go.
But we can fix this pretty easily.
Remember, how I said MCO was like knitting and you need to reference prior steps?
We're going to make that fix,
and we're going to fill that hole.
From the second row, references,
produce sheet, Remove Top headers. Here's our problem.
Removed top rows should be here instead of Filtered Rows.
This is trying to connect to a query step that no longer exists.
If I click that right there,
Done, our data pops back.
Easypeasy fund bu. Ready to give it a try?